- Why am I even trying to be a nurse? I'm gonna be delivering pizzas and cleaning carpets for the rest of my life.
NO!
- You're very attractive for a carpet cleaning lady, although you maybe could do something with your hair, you know?
No, that's not it. It's your face. Yeah.
Could you be a doll and get me a little smack?
- You know I was just hired to do carpets, right?
- You're fired.
- I bet you haven't worked a single day in your entire
self-absorbed life. Just pay me and I'll be on my way.
- Nope.
- No, no! My equipment!
- He is the devil.
- I owe the cleaning company 3000 bucks for a new machine,
and they fired me. Rich people can get away with everything.
- Help!
(splash)
- I don't know what day it is. I don't even know my own name.
- Amnesia in our little town.
- That's him.
- I have an idea that is poetic in its justice.
- I'm here to pick up my husband.
- You're really my wife?
- For better or worse, baby.
- I'm poor?
- Yep.
- Daddy!
- How come they don't look like me?
- We had to use a sperm donor.
- I'm sterile?
- You're getting picked up for work bright and early. (horn honks)
- I work? Three jobs.
Aw, I want a fake husband.
(mocking noises)
(laughter)
- Hi, honey! How was your first day?
- (mumbling)
- Do we need to take him to the hospital?
- I said Bobby.